here with more reaction former white
house uh chief of staff reince priebus
former white house press secretary
himself fox news contributor ari
fleischer are you smiling
i mean i'm listening to these answers
well the reason we're nakova testing
illegal immigrants is because they're
not going to be here very long we're
giving them uh request forms to show up
they're not even mandatory dates to show
up in court
we request you show up on this date but
that we're not going to force you to
show up now ari i have a funny feeling
nobody's going to show up
a funny feeling you have an accurate
feeling
sean
today is one of the most distressing
lowest moments i have ever seen in the
united states government
everything that joe biden said today
about this is not the american way that
this is a tragedy that this is not how
people should act
everything he said today should have
been said about those who are trying to
enter america illegally and not about
the people who were doing their job and
enforcing america's laws
this is a perfect illustration of how
the democrats led by joe biden are
anti-police anywhere and everywhere
that's his message today don't enforce
america's laws when you see somebody
breaking into our country let them in
he's also saying to police forces
everywhere no more horse patrols
anywhere has anybody's ever been to
bourbon street they have horse patrols
there is that somehow inhumane
the purpose of those patrols is to deter
people from coming into the country the
result of joe biden's policies is going
to invite many more people into the
country this is open borders at its
worst encouraged by the president of the
united states
just pick a few issues here reince okay
now we've we've achieved energy
independence for the first time in 75
years
uh for national security reasons it's
great we don't have to ask countries
that hate us to import oil we didn't
import any oil from saudi arabia in the
final months of the trump administration
uh we don't have to care about what
happens in the straits of hormuz where
iran plays a lot of games with the
world's oil supply what a third of which
comes through there
and then we're going to now joe is
begging opec to increase production
why doesn't joe go back to trump's
policies of energy independence like he
can go back to trump's policies on the
border like you go back to trump's
policies on monoclonal antibodies and
not abandoning americans in afghanistan
because they don't want to because it's
not who they are i don't think they care
about sovereignty i don't think they
actually care about borders
this is who they are
and every once in a while their
competency or their incompetency comes
to light you know you mentioned it
before joe biden playing the blame game
he blames the border patrol for uh
mistreating illegal illegal immigrants
he blames trump for the taliban being in
power he even blames uh his staff for
not calling on certain reporters that he
doesn't want to call unlike trump he'll
just say i'm not calling on you because
i think you're a liar
he just blames other people let's here's
my point
he can he has the opinions on these
issues
you know that biden rescinded and i just
wrote a list of like 10 things in a
second during your monologue he
rescinded the wall he rescinded zero
tolerance he rescinded the paris
agreement he rescinded the travel ban he
rescinded keystone he rescinded trump's
policy on transgender in the military
they have this view of america that is
not the view
that
most people in this country have and the
problem that biden has now is that when
because he ran as this guy of competency
when this mess on the border comes to
light because they don't care if
hundreds of thousands of people pour
over the border but every once in a
while they got a really bad camera shot
and they've got 15 000 haitians under a
bridge and people start wondering wait a
minute this guy's not very competent
they see what happens in afghanistan
thirteen service people are killed
tragically wait a minute this guy is not
competent and now you have democrats
which usually don't agree with us on the
border or on foreign policy a chunk of
those people are saying this guy's not
competent that's why his numbers are
sinking
you know i know a lot of people in the
media are a would feign outrage over
donald trump's mean tweeting they didn't
like it
um
donald trump wouldn't have abandoned
americans he wouldn't have given up
energy independence he wouldn't beg opec
donald trump would you know we had a
25-year low in terms of illegal
immigrants coming into the country uh we
didn't have a single american killed in
afghanistan in 18 months under his
policies they believed he would kill
them
i don't see that deterrent factor with
joe biden
no that's a that's exactly it look
donald trump was rude when he wanted to
be rude he could be a bull in the china
shop and everywhere he went he brought a
new china shop with him that's his style
but he caught people's attention he
changed the way we did business and he
was tremendously effective across the
board lowest poverty rate since 1959
china changing its behavior no new wars
started that's a result of policy and
it's why i'm a policy first person i
don't care if joe biden tweets or
doesn't tweet it's not what's relevant
to how you protect america enforce
america's laws move america forward
policy matters
when it comes to policy
joe biden is showing he is not up for
the job his judgment is wrong and he's a
liberal and liberal as liberal as it
gets and everything he's trying to shove
through is a left-wing wish list
will donald trump try and come back
reince priebus
uh i i think almost certainly uh he's
going to run again but look joe biden
you become a failure when you start
blaming others for your own mistakes and
policy is who you are r is right and the
policies of joe biden is what will undo
him but yeah now trump's going to run
and
um we'll have a we'll have a big race
upcoming in 2024 but we'll worry about
2022 next
that's true and i will tell you this i
think people will be less concerned
about the tweets and more concerned
about being competent and actually
knowing what day of the week it is just
my guess uh
what a i i never would have guessed we'd
abandon americans and that this disaster
at the border i never guessed we'd be
begging opec to produce more oil
and that's just touching the surface
thank you all hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else